uh yes it is all right what do you got
for me man what's this what's the super
chat about well
um
good question
um you you do want to sell more of your
books I take it I mean you I don't know
how many you've sold so far but um
you need to get a lot of eyeballs uh on
your advertisements to to sell more to
sell a half million or a million copies
and Andrew Tate has the ability to do
that for you
and there's a reason why he would do
that okay because you know you a favor
okay
so
um
you know he's under house arrest and and
uh
he's very limited in what he can do in
his actions he has access to Twitter
I don't think he's putting a lot of
other content out because I think he's
he's probably has some pretty strong
restrictions on what he can can and
can't say
so
what I think you could use your
connections because you've been doing
this for over 10 years and you you have
actually interviewed the guy before so
you may be able to reach out and contact
him and then you could have him
um put out a tweet calling for his
followers to
um a call to action
so look I get what you're saying but
I don't run that way dude like I can
message Andrew right now on WhatsApp and
he'll respond I I okay is uh you know
Jewel this arterial shooter
I've seen some videos of him recently
yeah he's the tall Australian guy that
runs in his crew we you know we chat I
helped him out with stuff in his in his
uh personal life
um look you know when he says to me hey
you know do me a favor I'd like to you
know hop on a podcast to talk about what
Andrew can't talk about right now I
don't say you know I'll do that if you
put a tweet out selling my book I just
don't care you know I do it because I
find it interesting like I'm not in that
economy where it's like well you know if
I scratch your back then you scratch
mine it's like I'll scratch your back I
like what you're doing I want to have a
conversation with you tell me what's
going on tell me about Islam why do you
live in Dubai sort of thing and you know
let's you know if there's if there's
stuff that they want to get out about
what's happened with Andrew since he's
been out of jail I'm happy to talk about
that too but I'm not going to be like
I'll only do that if you talk about my
book or put out a tweet right okay okay
that's fine that's just how I am though
there are reasons why other reason why
he would want to do that
um to Andrews Andrew's a self-promoter
he he's not the kind of guy that's going
to promote other people's stuff right
that's exactly
exactly right but the thing about the I
think people don't understand about Tate
is that he talks like a revolutionary
but he's more of an entrepreneur right
he's promoting his own ideas and
directing people to his uh his
university as Huskers University to make
money are you a part of his Huskers
University uh no I'm not okay but what
I'm saying is that is that if he was an
actual revolutionary then he would he
would have a superpower he he has these
all these followers that he can
influence with a call to action
and and what this call Action would be
would be to get his followers
to donate one book to their school's
library in order to create a a personal
development and young entrepreneurs
library in each School
that his followers attend
okay so and then look man I appreciate
what you're trying to do but I I've got
it under control my man do you have any
other questions or anything around the
topic of money tonight
no I figured as an entrepreneur you'd be
interested in hearing more about that
um I mean trust me my I'm I'm doing just
fine but I appreciate the uh chime in
though thanks Craig see you buddy I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full-length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out